sin duda el sistema de la República
islámica no ha entendido incluso todavía
la dimensión de la indignación y de la
rabia que tuvo un gran sector de la
población especialmente joven y
especialmente mujer cuando se conoció lo
que había pasado con maxam y una joven
de 22 años que estaba de visita en
Teherán caminaba por la ciudad cuando
fue detenida por una de esas patrullas
de la moral y dos horas más tarde era
llevada con muerte cerebral al hospital
muchas de esas jóvenes que están en la
calle han sido víctimas también de esas
patrullas y saben que muchas veces
actúan de manera violenta y algunos
testigos aseguran que esta mujer fue
golpeada aunque las autoridades todavía
aseguran que ella murió como
consecuencia de una enfermedad que tuvo
en su infancia lo que crea mayor
indignación dentro de la población que
sigue protestando no solamente en
Teherán sino unas grandes ciudades del
país y esto se hace especialmente
evidente en la región del curdistán de
donde es originaria
donde la represión ha aumentado incluso
más en los últimos días se habla de
grandes enfrentamientos se habla de
patrullas de la policía yendo a sacar a
personas de sus casas explosiones y se
habla de menos 5000 detenidos solamente
en esa zona del país hoy hablaba el jefe
de la justicia iraní y decía que los
principales protagonistas de estas
movilizaciones de estos disturbios como
los llaman tenían que tener fuertes
sentencias que así se lo había ordenado
a sus jueces y que el resto de la
población que está así aparte de ellos
tenía que ser juzgado y salir
rápidamente pero también el debate que
se ha creado en estas últimas semanas es
el velo a estas horas muchas mujeres
caminan por las calles de Teherán y de
las grandes ciudades sin velo y el uno
de los asesores del líder supremo de la
Revolución exporta voz del parlamento
alilar y Yani hablaba de que si el 50%
de las mujeres no quieren usar el velo
habría que abrir esa conversación porque
no se le pueden poner a importante que
hacer Así que el debate está abierto
falta ver que dice la parte más radical
de la República islámica y saber cómo
van a seguir gestionando estas protestas